il a marché sur la lune
il amorçait son aide si besoin
[Applaudissements]
2 avril bonsoir cette géniale et précis
alors buzz aldrin vous êtes présents à
paris dans le cadre du 12e festival du
film jules verne dont le président est
james cameron c'est du 9 au 16 mars au
grand rex
un jury décernera le jules verne award
du meilleur documentaire et le 11 mars
il ya une nuits thématiques nuit du ciel
et de l'espace où vous étiez l'invité
spécial
le grand sujet de cette nuit du 11 mars
c'était la planète mars
est ce que vous croyez buzz aldrin qu'on
peut se baigner sur mars
je ne pense pas qu'on puisse s'y baigner
la classe au pôle de mars en dessous du
sol peut-être mais certainement pas de
cette façon-là
dommage dans tous les cas vous pensez
qu'il faut aller sur mars et vous êtes
persuadé qu'un jour l'homme se
dispersera sur les différentes planètes
éclatèrent restera la planète de la
génèse je crois que les êtres humains
doivent à un stade de à venir dans
l'avenir devront s'établit aller habiter
en dehors de la terre de manière à ce
que si un jour la terre devait amener
être détruite qu'il y ait une
possibilité de survie de notre
civilisation et nous avons cette
responsabilité là à l'égard des
générations à venir
alors voilà c'est très impressionnant de
vous recevoir buzz aldrin vous êtes vous
est pour nous un vrai héros vous êtes le
vétéran du premier alunissage en 1969 la
mission apollo 11
c'est un petit peu un héros comme dans
les légendes antiques y avait les
lys lez hérault 2 2 au maire vous dites
les minutes les plus exaltantes de ma
mission furent la descente en modules
vers la lune parce que à ce moment là
quand quand vous quittez le vaisseau
spatial et que le module lem descend
vers la lune
à un moment il ya une panne d'ordinateur
je crois non heureusement l'ordinateur
pas eu une panne complète simplement il
y avait une légère surcharge et nous
avions du mal à avoir nos affichage
anormaux donc c'est vrai que c'est un
petit peu distrait notre attention mais
un contrôleur à houston
très intelligemment a compris où était
le problème est très rapidement il nous
a dit tout va bien vous pouvez y aller
il était acceptable que nous y allions
que nous à l'unission c'est vrai que ça
a duré un peu plus longtemps que prévu
et on était un petit peu à l'écart il
nous manquait un peu de carburant
oui c'était juste nous n'avions que plus
que ce 15 secondes de carburant quand
ils ont un axe trop rire quand ils ont à
l'unil là resté quinze secondes de
carburant et c'est neil amstrong qui est
qui qui a pris les commandes et qui a
posé le lem le module lunaire dans un
endroit qui n'était pas celui qui était
qui était prévu c'est à 7 kilomètres de
là voilà alors tout se passe bien et
neil amstrong le capitaine de la mission
demande d'avancer la sortie sur la lune
ça s'est tellement bien passé qui sont
sortis plutôt et et quand il évidemment
on pose le pied sur le sol lunaire il a
cette phrase qui restera pour l'éternité
graver un petit pas pour l'homme un bond
de géant pour l'humanité
c'est excellent ça c'est un slogan qui a
été trouvé par une agence de madison
avenue où ça mon avis des conseils
auprès de quelqu'un d'autre
je sais que personnellement en tout cas
j'aurai
demandez conseil à quelqu'un d'autre
s'ils savaient bien et c'est moi qui
avais dû le faire il est allé plus ce
soir il a marché sur la lune
[Applaudissements]
abba
alors
le le premier de wikio c'est le premier
qui descend c'est neil armstrong
et quand vous le rejoignez quelques
quelques instants plus tard sur le sol
lunaire
votre première remarque c'est de dire
c'est une magnifique désolation
c'est pas du tout un endroit où on
aimerait rester là l'humain c'est pas
sympathique n'y a pas un bistrot à tout
est gris vous dit tout est gris c'est
que des différents gris plus belle
phrase m'est venue à l'esprit
pour expliquer ces extrêmes c'est-à-dire
cet accomplissement incroyable cet
exploit et puis le côté désolé parce
qu'il n'y avait aucune vie simplement
différentes nuances de gris
la seule couleur qu'on voyait c'était la
couleur que nous avions avec nous alors
vous dites vue de la lune la terre
apparaît quatre fois plus grande
mais nous semblait loi est pourtant un
milliard de spectateurs vous regarde ce
soir-là et rigolent quand vous marchez
comme un comme un kangourou ni le monde
entier avait les yeux rivés sur nous
mais le rêve était sur la terre sur la
lune
il n'y avait donc siete et conscience de
la charge c'est à dire ce que vous dites
en fait c'est que le plus important dans
toute cette histoire c'est pas les
cailloux qui ont été collectés sur la
lune le plus importante pour vous c'est
l'expérience personnelle vécue par tous
les terriens tout à fait ce sont les
genres et rester sur terre qui ont eu le
plaisir de ce succès et qu'ils ont c'est
vrai avec nous et nous qui étions très
intéressé par le succès c'est vrai qu'on
avait beaucoup à faire
on n'a pas vraiment partagé célébration
ça nous est passé à côté
oui c'est vrai que tout le monde se
souvient de ce qu'il faisait ce jour-là
dire que tout le monde sur la terre
qu'ils étaient vivants à ce moment là
dit j'étais à tel endroit avec telle
personne
c'est un moment qui a fédéré toute
l'humanité ce extraordinaire
je crois que moi aussi je m'en
souviendrai pour l'éternité
la frustration de celui qui reste dans
la cabine qui fait partie de l'équipe et
qui nient troisième il n'est pas
descendu le louisiana qui n'est pas
descendu ouais bah oui et lui d arrivée
deuxième alors c'est bien deux
prochaines grandes que j'aime bien non
mais c'est vrai que cette convergence
comme ça sur vous à ce moment là cette
nuit là donnent à ce voyage une
dimension spirituelle extraordinaire
bien au delà de l'exploit technique
d'une certaine façon c'est vrai c'est
vous qui avez dit ça mais vous avez
raison
j'avais le sentiment qu'il fallait
exprimé les remerciements pour le succès
de cette année ni sage et sans le dire à
d'autres cette époque là c'est vrai que
je me suis certains pays j'ai payé la
communion vous savez avec une aussi oui
oui bien sûr vous avez emporté dans le
module lunaire à un mini accessoires de
communion c'est à dire un calice et une
hostie un signe ostentatoire voilà un
signe ostentatoire et une fois sur la
lune vous communier après avoir demandé
une minute de silence à la base de
houston et pourtant votre ardeur
religieuse de l'époque donc mais pas
sortis renforcés mais plutôt diminué par
ce voyage je crois que c'est vrai que la
réflexion a été amené à maturité
j'ai vu les choses façon plus large je
crois que mes opinions sur la religion
la spiritualité sont nettement plus
large elle bloque toute l'humanité plus
que par le passé peut-être je ne me
concentre plus sur une religion ou une
secte donné c'est bien donc
ceci étant au retour buzz aldrin vous
avez un certain nombre de problèmes des
malaises
une dépression traitement psychologique
et puis aussi l'alcoolisme et et vous
dites ça a été plus dur de sortir de
l'alcool que d'aller sur la lune
probablement ce que j'ai vécu de plus
difficile mais récemment j'ai fêté les
25 ans de ma sobriété
[Applaudissements]
ça s'arrose scotch buzz est ce qu'il y à
un moune blues parce que il paraît que
les douze personnes qui ont marché sur
la lune ont des dépressions oui est ce
que c'est ça est ce que c'est parce
qu'une fois qu'on est allé sur la lune
on sait plus quoi faire sur la terre
finalement je sais très bien ce que je
dois faire j'essaye d'améliorer le
programme spatial et d'en aider d'autres
à aller dans les sas à retourner sur la
lune et au bout du compte amener des
êtres humains à aller sur mars
alors besoin drid ans a raconté que
durant ce voyage vous auriez vu des
choses que la nasa
vous aurez interdit de de révéler à
votre retour
est-ce que vous avez vu des petits
hommes verts ou des trucs
extraordinaires que dont vous auriez pas
le droit de parler certainement pas mais
il ya une chose qu'on a découvert quand
même depuis votre voyage c'est en 1999
quand il ya eu les 30 ans du voyage sur
la lune
on a découvert dans les archives du
gouvernement américain que si l époque
qu'il y avait eu un problème si vous
n'aviez pas été capable de remonter
depuis la lune jusque dans le vaisseau
spatial si le lem n'était pas arrivé a
redécollé le lem c'est un petit peu le
maillon faible de l'opération la nasa
avait décidé à ce moment là de couper
les communications et on vous aurait
laissé mourir sur la lune sans vous voir
et vous entendre mais c'est quelque
chose que à laquelle je ne m'attendais
au moment où s'est révélé au public
évidemment le public attiré olala ils
ont pensé à ça ils ont pensé que vous
pourriez mourir donc il couperait les
communications et puis le président
évidemment il y avait préparé un
discours qui devait dire en cas d'échec
vous avez eu peur là-haut sérieusement
quand vous étiez la ola sur la lune vous
avez eu peur de quoi
battus en corée j'ai descendu deux
avions
c'est à mesure que ça ça vous donne une
préoccupation pour conclure
buzz aldrin qu'est ce que ça vous a
apporté cette histoire qu'est ce que
vous avez appris dans toute cette
histoire
wadih douleur j'ai appris que lorsque
notre pays décide de faire quelque chose
on réagit on répond tu avec force et je
crois que la raison pour laquelle nous
sommes allés sur la lune c'était de
battre les russes parce que le monde
était menacée par le communisme
soviétique et leur armement nucléaire et
je crois qu'ils se sont rendus compte au
moment où nous sommes arrivés sur la
lune avant eux qu'ils n'allaient pas
pouvoir continuer comme cela
les choses commençaient l'union
soviétique commençait à faiblir à ce
moment là puis plus tard lorsque notre
président a lancé un défi à la russie
dans le domaine de la défense les
systèmes de défense en utilisant
l'espace
la russie s'est aperçue qu'elle ne
pouvait tout simplement pas être à la
hauteur
mais tout cela remonte à l'époque nous
sommes arrivés sur la lune les premiers
et c'est un des éléments les plus
importants d'une certaine manière la
paix dans le monde
aujourd'hui elle est liée au fait que
nous sommes allés sur la lune buzz
aldrin est ce que vous préférez les
américains quand ils vont sur la ligne
quand ils envahissent l'irak
je suis fier que soient les faits puis
le dirigeant je crois qu'ils comprennent
la situation qui prévaut dans le monde
et ils savent ce qu'il faut faire nous
voulons là
dans le monde nous sommes allés sur la
lune dans un esprit de paix pour
l'humanité toute entière nous sommes
allés en irak dans un esprit de paix et
pour l'humanité toute entière
je vais pas discuter avec vous non parce
qu'il a marché sur la lune
voilà exactement 5 you very much invité
d'honneur du 12e
festival jules verne du 9 au 16 mars au
grand rex
merci tels google mail
[Musique]